i think it would be
interesting to hear what your opinions
are on just how
exciting surprising profound
interesting or boring the
breakthrough uh performance of alpha
zero was
okay so alphago knocked my socks off
that was that was so remarkable which
aspect of it
that that they they got it to work that
they actually were able to
leverage a whole bunch of different
ideas integrate them into one
giant system just the software
engineering aspect of it
is mind-blowing i don't i i've never
been a part of a program as complicated
as the program that they built for that
and um and just the you know like like
jerry tessaro is a neural net whisperer
like you know david silver is a kind of
neural net whisperer too he was able to
coax these networks
and these new way out their
architectures to do
these you know solve these problems that
um as you said
you know when we were learning from uh
ai
no one had an idea how to make it work
it was it was remarkable
that um these you know these these
techniques that were so good at playing
chess and they could beat the world
champion in chess
couldn't beat you know your typical go
playing teenager and go
so the fact that that you know in a very
short number of years we kind of ramped
up to
trouncing people and go just blew me
away
so you're kind of focusing on the
engineering aspect which is also very
surprising
i mean there's something different about
large well-funded companies i mean
there's a compute aspect to it too
sure like that of course
i mean that's similar to deep blue right
with uh with ibm
like there's something important to be
learned and remembered about a large
company taking the ideas that are
already out there
and investing a few million dollars into
it or
or more and so you're kind of saying the
engineering is kind of fascinating both
on the
with alphago is probably just gathering
all the data
right of the expert games like
organizing everything
actually doing distributed uh supervised
learning
and to me
see the engineering i kind of took for
granted
to me philosophically being able to
persist
in the in the face of like long odds
because it feels like for me i'll be one
of the skeptical people in the room
thinking that you can learn your way to
to beat go like i it sounded like
especially with david silver it sounded
like david was not
confident at all it's like it was like
not it's funny how confidence works
yeah it's like you're not like cocky
about it
like but right because if you're cocky
about it you
kind of stop and stall and don't get
anywhere yeah but there's like a
hope that's unbreakable maybe that's
better than confidence it's a kind of
wishful
hope and a little dream and you almost
don't want to do anything else you kind
of
keep doing it that's that seems to be
the story
and but with enough skepticism that
you're looking for where the problems
are and fighting
through them yeah because you know
there's got to be a way out of this
thing yeah
and for him it was probably there's
there's a bunch of little factors that
come into play it's funny how these
stories just all come together like
everything he did in his life
came into play which is like a love for
video games
and also a connection to so the the 90s
had to happen
with td gammon and so on yeah in some
ways it's surprising
maybe you can provide some intuition to
it that
not much more than td gammon was done
for quite a long time
on the reinforcement learning front yeah
is that weird to you
i mean like i said the the students who
i worked with we tried to get
basically apply that architecture to
other problems and
we consistently failed there were a
couple
a couple really nice demonstrations that
ended up being in the literature there
was a
paper about controlling elevators right
where it's it's like okay
can we modify the heuristic that
elevators use for deciding like a bank
of elevators for deciding
which floors we should be stopping on to
maximize throughput essentially and you
can set that up as a reinforcement
learning problem and you can
you know have a neural net represent the
value function so that it's taking
where all the elevators where the button
pushes you know this high dimensional
well at the time high dimensional input
um you know a couple dozen dimensions
and turn that into a prediction as to oh
is it going to be better if i stop at
this floor or not
and ultimately it appeared as though for
the
standard simulation distribution for
people trying to leave the building at
the end of the day
that the neural net learned a better
strategy than the standard one that's
implemented in
elevator controllers so that that was
nice uh there was
some work that surtender singh it all
did on
handoffs with cell phones uh you know
deciding
when when should you hand off from this
cell tower to this cell
okay communication networks yeah yeah
and so
a couple things seemed like they were
really promising none of them made it
into production that i'm aware of
and neural nets as a whole started to
kind of implode around then
and so there just wasn't a lot of air in
the room for people to try to figure out
okay how do we get this to work
in the rl setting and then they they
found their way back in
in 10 in 10 plus years so you said
alphago is impressive like it's a big
spectacle is there right so then alpha's
zero so i think i
i may have a slightly different opinion
on this than some people so
um i talked to satinder saying in
particular about this so satinder was
like rich sutton a student of antibartow
so they came out of the same lab
very influential machine learning
reinforcement learning researcher
uh now deep mind uh as as is rich
though different sites the two of them
he's in alberta
rich is in alberta and uh satinder would
be in england but i think he's in
england from michigan at the moment
uh but the but he was yes he was much
more impressed with
uh alpha zero
which is didn't didn't get a kind of a
bootstrap in the beginning with human
trained games and it's just was purely
self-play
though the first one alpha go was also a
tremendous amount of self-play
right they started off they kick-started
the the action network that was making
decisions
but then they trained it for a really
long time using more traditional
temporal difference methods um so so as
a result i didn't it didn't seem
that different to me like it seems like
yeah why wouldn't that work
like once once it works it works so
what but he he found that that removal
of that extra information to be
breathtaking like that that's a game
changer to me the first thing was more
of a game changer but
the open question i mean i guess that's
the assumption
is the expert games might contain with
them
within them a
humongous amount of information but we
know that it went beyond that
right we know that it somehow got away
from that information because it was
learning strategies i don't think it
i don't think alphago is just better at
implementing human strategies i think it
actually developed its own strategies
that were
that was more effective and so from that
perspective
okay well so it made at least one
quantum leap in terms of strategic
knowledge
okay so now maybe it makes three like
okay but that first one is the doozy
right
getting it to to work reliably and
and for the networks to to hold on to
the value well enough like that was
that was a big step well isn't maybe you
could speak to this on the reinforcement
learning front so the
starting from scratch and learning to
do something like the first like
like random behavior to like
crappy behavior to like somewhat okay
behavior
it's not obvious to me that that's not
like impossible to take those steps like
if you just think about the intuition
like how the heck does
random behavior become somewhat
basic intelligent behavior not not human
level not super human level but just
basic but you're saying to you
kind of the intuition is like if if you
can go from human to superhuman level
intelligence on the
uh on this particular task of game
playing then
so you're good at taking leaps so you
can take many of them the system i
believe that the system can take
that kind of leap yeah no and also i
think that that beginner knowledge
in go like you can start to get a feel
really quickly
for the idea that um you know certain
parts of the being in certain parts of
the board seems to be
more associated with winning right
because it's not
it's not stumbling upon the concept of
winning it's told that it wins
or that it loses well it's self-play so
it both wins and loses it's told
which which side won and the information
is kind of there to start
percolating around to make a difference
as to
um well these things have a better
chance of helping you win and these
things have a worse chance of helping
you win and so
you know it can get to basic play i
think pretty quickly
then once it has basic play well now
it's kind of forced to do some search to
actually experiment with okay well what
gets me that next
increment of of improvement
you